thoughts feelings emotions i am
literally in heaven right now
[Music]
hey thanks for being here i know i've
been a little slow with these uploads
and it means a lot that you stick around
if you're new here i'm christian i'm an
outdoor adventure photographer living on
the road full time for three and a half
years
last month i parked the van and left it
behind for three weeks to explore italy
and switzerland and as i'm finally
sitting down to edit this it's been a
while since i've returned home from
europe i've been putting off this edit
for so long i nearly abandoned it all
together i've formed the bad habit of
waiting too long to piece together
footage and with this trip the amount of
clips that i had piled up was almost too
much but more importantly i just didn't
know what kind of story i wanted to tell
i'm still learning how to pick up the
camera and hit record during the less
photo worthy scenes
i guess in a way i'm having to unlearn a
lot of the habits i've formed as a
landscape photographer i'm starting to
realize that the normal moments are
sometimes even more important than the
epic beautiful ones but anyway in the
end i decided it was better to share
rather than worry about it being perfect
or even making sense
that's life anyway isn't it just one big
beautiful mess so here's mine from last
month where we left off in switzerland
[Music]
this is what it's like to eat dinner
with a bunch of photographers
you got enough there this is how i like
it
that might be too dark i don't know
[Music]
[Music]
guys
[Music]
here we have nathaniel wise getting his
tree frames in the wild
so these are large trees
and they're so soft to the touch
like velvet
just go stand on that rock right there
okay we're gonna go stand on the rock
i need you to go to a lower rock
we went the wrong way
oh we're trying to find the trail before
sunset
bouldering
[Music]
my lens
grab oh maybe they're just stopping the
swiss side
maybe we're okay
grazie
we made it to italy oh there's a castle
oh hello
right now we're in italy
we're in the wall city
wow
so cool
we are heading to lonzano and then we're
going to order but right now we are on
hunt for gelato all right we just parked
this one's 4.6 gelato yeah let's go
there yes so it's just back here i think
to gelato
[Music]
here we have ali
hello in our italian abode matthew
wow
beautiful butterflies
here we have nathaniel
and our kitchen with renee roaming as
usual
here's our other little kitchen table
and here is one bedroom this is our
bedroom
very nice very spacious
and
we have bathroom here bathroom here it's
getting dark bedroom here it's too dark
to film oh my gosh here we go here's the
last bedroom so pretty spacious
this is home sweet home for the next
four days yes
meanwhile i'm instagram
we are fully touristing enough right now
but look at that mountain
[Music]
this town is so cool
all right good morning it's the next day
it we woke up at 3 45 a.m
and it's now 4 30 and we're heading back
up to the trailhead
to
hopefully
catch an epic sunrise up at sashaydah
wish us luck we're hoping for some good
conditions golden light it is 3.5 miles
3000 feet elevation gain and it is
freaking cold outside it's like 25
degrees so
yeah it's gonna be a workout and super
chilly but here we go are you stoked
he's so stoked
so cold
it really is
[Music]
hey kitty
hi
how's it going
[Music]
taking a break
[Applause]
okay
see
morendo
so
[Music]
lately i've been struggling to balance
my time between photography and
videography
especially when the light is nice i'm
torn between taking photos and filming
and also whether i should be in the
frame or just focus on the scenery
it's kind of frustrating sometimes being
in front of the camera when i really
just want to be shooting but those
scenes also make it easier to tell a
story so i'm grateful for the times my
friends helped capture moments that
would be hard to do otherwise
but to be real with you
i sometimes find it challenging to
travel with other creatives in a lot of
ways
every day starts to feel like work it
starts to feel like everything has to be
captured and we all feel pressured to do
it in our own creative way
sometimes it was difficult to know which
moments were real and which moments were
just for the camera
i feel like i'm forever walking this
fine line of artist and subject creative
and participant
it's difficult when those rules spill
over into your personal life when your
co-workers and colleagues are also your
friends
it's easy enough to piece together a
string of beautiful moments throw a
happy song over it and call it a day
but that just isn't the whole story like
deciding whether to take a photo or film
a video i guess i'm still just searching
for the right balance of sharing the
carefree and beautiful moments of this
lifestyle alongside the difficulties and
challenges
because there's always a little bit of
both
these layers are insane
they're everywhere
[Music]
so
my home
is not a highway
a straight
road
too
[Music]
i wrote
thoughts feelings emotions i am
literally in heaven right now
this is like dream conditions i'm so
excited
[Music]
it's turning so pink like look at these
peaks this is so crazy
i'm freaking out i'm this is like my
dreamscape right here
[Music]
[Music]
if this trip has taught me anything it's
that i want more moments with my friends
that don't involve a camera more sunsets
and sunrises spent just enjoying each
other's company rather than trying to
capture it because i'm lucky to have
some pretty amazing people in my life
and 50 years from now i'd like to say
that i made the most of my time with
them
i originally thought this would be the
last video to round out the europe trip
but i was wrong going through this
footage there were entire days and
adventures i had completely forgotten
about we did so much in our time over
there it just wasn't easy to remember it
all
i guess that's another reason why i love
having this channel it motivates me to
make these videos which are fun to share
but they also serve as a visual journal
of sorts memories made and moments
shared that i don't ever want to forget
so thanks for being here and i will see
you in the next one